bienvenue chez high ku robotique
mesdames et messieurs vous êtes prêts à
découvrir le truc qui va tout changer
alors faites du bruit pour le nouveau
chef c'est trop cool thèmes plus les
robots que moi
toby coach souris les enfants doivent
être accompagnés d'un adulte
veuillez me suivre jeune dame non
hu
[Musique]
bonjour oui moi on pourrait peut-être
essayer d'être ami tu vas rester là ça
coince à trois mots je le savais tu te
fiches de moi mec
plus belle chose qui me soit jamais
arrivée
quoi vous mettriez une arme dans un
robot drame est sur le point d'arriver
l'un d'une tartine à bulles 77,23 est
notre seul espoir
au fleuret
tous
fellah
[Musique]
genre vachement trop d'injustices dans
le monde
ensemble on va pouvoir régler ça
te promets que je ne te laisserai jamais
tomber
quoi
non
il est trop cool ces trucs comment
t'appelles ça un ami
[Musique]
merci de m'avoir ouvert
attention je meurs ferme
[Musique]